Happy Star Wars Friday everybody's we have to freak out about Episode 8 Force Friday
stuff happening this year.
So I'm going to explain what's going on and what it says about the movie if you guys didn't
know I'm doing Star Wars Fridays where I do a Star Wars bonus video every Friday, no matter
what's going on during the week.
if you're brand-new to the channel, be sure to subscribe to get everything and leave all
your requests in the comments below.
the big thing this Friday everyone's freaking out about is they revealed force Friday 2
packaging that actually gives us a look at Rey's character and it confirms a couple big
things about the movie there are some other things that also dropped backing that up that
I'll explain.
But really this is all about Rey's character.
There's also a new round of the Star Wars
giveaway that starts now, it's for a copy of
the Rogue One DVD.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Star Wars comment on this video
the 10 big takeaways from this are #10.
If you don't remember what Star Wars force Friday is, it was a giant worldwide toy un-boxing
event where they revealed all the new toy lines based on the new movies we already got a  look
at some of the packaging, so you had a pretty good idea what some of the black series looked like. It was basically this
#9 The really cool thing is I'll be doing some stuff for that later this year too. Of course
I'll be giving away a lot of Star Wars toys when the movie gets ready to come out.
It'll be a lot of fun but Star Wars force Friday 2 is happening this September, so you don't
have to wait that long.
The movie is not coming out till December.
You do not have to wait till December to get all those new toys.
Surprisingly that just seems like a good business decision from Star Wars.
Please if you want to tell us to shut up and take our money, we will allow you to do that
#8 the other things going to be
coming back around.
Is Ryan Johnson the director also teased cool stuff for Star Wars celebration that's happening
April 13-16th I know I do Star
Wars Friday, so I do Star Wars videos every week
Anyway, but that's gonna be a comic con style weekend whether it's just a bunch of Star Wars
stuff happening all within a really small span of time it is gonna be crazy.
There's some larger stuff rumblings behind-the-scenes
that I'll explain later on this list, so
#7 the big stuff, Rey has a very Qui-Gon Jinn looking haircut in this.
If you remember Anakin's padawan haircut.
He had the shaved sides, the braid.
Male padawans have different hairstyles than
female padawans, female padawans look like this.
It confirms a whole bunch of stuff in connection
with #6 the updated foreign titles.
There were new Latin American and Italian
posters posted to the official Facebook pages
of Star Wars that confirmed plural Jedi.
So the last of the Jedi just means that there's no one single Jedi left so that is one
theory that you can cross off your list.
It doesn't confirm who the last Jedi are it
just confirms that there's more than one.
So it confirms Luke, Rey, but there's also the theory that Kylo Ren and even Snoke could
be the last Jedi, because we know so little about his back story we know a lot about him politically.
I did a video about that, because he has history with Leia, so I'll add a link at the end of this.
but the reason why that's so huge,
is just because even though there's
a seismic shift in the teachings of the Jedi
in these new films, the 'Jedi' term will still apply.
It's pretty much confirms that. Like,  there'll always be Jedi in Star Wars, even though they won't
look anything like the Jedi that you've seen before. #5 the other people on that poster,
Finn and Poe don't really look any
different than they did in The Force Awakens,
but characters go through a number of different costume changes during the movie,
Finn went from his Stormtrooper armor to, being stripped
down, to going to post resistance jacket,
there's a lot of rumors about what Finn is doing in the movie so I'll briefly address that.
But it's a little bit of speculation.
It just implies that he's going to be thrown back into the path of the First Order,
which gives us an idea how we might run into the Phasma character, because she is so important
for Finns character, if she's gonna show up again during Episode 8 and they did confirm
that she has a much bigger part than she did in Episode 7.  The most rewarding way to
do that would be to circle back around to the way she left things with Finn.
Throw him back into her path that she can get a little bit of revenge, but Finn can also carry out
whatever mission he's on, because his spine is healed, he's standing upright here and he wants
nothing more than to help the resistance.
Now he is fully committed to the cause.
There is some speculation the goes a little bit beyond that.
Maybe I'll do that in a separate video, if you want to talk about that there been a lot
of rumors about what actually Finn is doing
during the movie you can do that in the comments below,
but just remember that it's speculation
at this point. #4 The Last Jedi.
So there were a lot of theories like I said before this title dropped about who that was.
We can't discount Kylo Ren because Snoke looks like he's trying to create a super Jedi.
They're talking about a New Order.
So it goes way beyond what's happening with the Knights of Ren, the  Knights of Ren is not
the New Order that Snoke is making, they're just an elite group of Darkside Force Users
put together by Snoke to carry out special missions separate from the rest of the First Order
they're not the great Force Wielders that he's hoping to create in Kylo Ren.
He actually had an apprentice before he met Kylo Ren.
So while most of our focus is on Rey becoming a Jedi; she has the padawan haircut, she has
the Lightsaber, she's training with Luke. You cannot forget about Kylo Ren being the last of the Jedi.
#3 on the flipside of this,
how are the Jedi changing?
So I did a video about the Bendu, the diBendu, sort of the original beliefs of the Jedi
and how they're being incorporated into these new films.
So while the term 'Jedi' will still apply. The way they become Jedi, the way they practice
the Force, the way they will that will be very different.
So if don't watch Star Wars Rebels and you didn't see the Bendu video that I did.
It's really just a different approach to the Force that does not discount the use of the
Darkside it's sort of something in the middle, Grey Jedi like Asoka is kind of a term for
that but technically she's not Bendu.
Just to clarify, when I say Bendu a lot of
people were confused about this the Bendu is not the name of his race, it's a very Yoda
type twist in that we don't know the true name of Yodas species, George Lucas was famous
for never truly revealing a lot of Yodas
origins.
They were just meant to be very mysterious.
So in that way the Bendu is very mysterious.
Bendu is the name of his order.
So it's like calling someone a Jedi, you go to see the Jedi, you go to see the Bendu.
But when people think about Jedi training in the old films, you see Master Yoda lecturing
in the Jedi Temple people learning in classes.
It's a very rigid way to learn and wield the Force. These are the things you're allowed to do.
You must be passionless, no attachments, no spouses, no children. The wrinkle in that,
during the prequel's was Qui Gon Jin and his use of the Living Force, so #2.
Remember that the prequel's are still cannon.
They haven't changed the way that the Living Force and the Cosmic Force work.
Midichlorians are technically still cannon.
Even though they've erased all mention of them from the new Star Wars films.
Do not expect to hear about Midichlorians, even though technically they still exist.
But, the Living Force if you didn't know is the energy field generated by all living things.
It's what enables Qui-Gon, Yoda,
Obi-Wan, Anakin to become force ghosts, and
continue speaking with the living.
The Cosmic Force is the connective tissue that connects
everything at a cosmic level across the galaxy
is not really important.
But the Midichlorians are basically like the Wi-Fi receptors in all living things that
allow the Living Force to connect with the Cosmic Force, so all the stuff is still cannon,
but the gonna do it in a really simple easy
to follow way in the new films. The Jedi never
spent a lot of time in the old films studying the Living Force and they avoided practices
favored by Darkside Force Users.
That's part of what's changing in the new films.
Forget about the things they told you not to do, the things they told you not to study.
We're going to be learning a new way, a new path.
So it just confirms that there will always
be Jedi in Star Wars, even though what the
Jedi: look like, the way they practice and wield
The Force will be very different. Imagine them
trying to get rid of the word Jedi, it would
be a crazy branding nightmare.
It would be like trying to get rid of the
word Lightsaber, all the merchandising would
fall down the toilet.
That's what made George Lucas a billionaire;
not the films, the merchandise made him all
that money.
#1. The really important thing that's coming up
pretty soon.
They've confirmed a Star Wars Episode Eight
panel at Star Wars celebration April 13-16
The panel's gonna be happening on
Friday, they're probably going to bring a trailer
like they did to the Episode 7 panel at
celebration and a behind-the-scenes reel
they brought way more than the Episode 7
trailer when they came to celebration there
was a whole bunch of extra footage too, so
it will be a really big deal which is part
of the reason why you haven't seen Episode 8 trailer yet, because they're just waiting for that.
Of course, I'm gonna be doing a whole
bunch of videos for that, but if you want to
suggest bonus Star Wars videos for me to do
each week before then.
Just write them below in the comments. It seems
that most of you have liked Star Wars Fridays.
So far, so I'm making that a permanent thing.
Star Wars videos every Friday, no matter what's happening,
till the end of time.
I'm in be doing the same thing for other stuff like: Spider-Man, The Flash, Sunday's usually
supposed to be a Game of Thrones day for me, but you get the idea.
So will make a video update when I decide;
what days are going to be what videos, but
Congratulations to last week's Star Wars giveaway
winner Reagan Hughes! Please private message
me on the back end my channel so I can get
your contact details. What can happen next is,
There is a 'mystery name' or 'Marvel
project' that is filming in Hawaii, so I'm going to do
a video all about that, because it raises
so many questions.
So thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys and that next video.
While you wait for that, you can click here
to learn all about Snoke's Backstory and you
can click here for the Black Panther/Infinity War     teaser video!